hey guys it is Friday and before you
head off your weekend I've got all the
biggest news in gaming ready to go for
you that's up the PlayStation Store has
revealed what's in the season pass for
Final Fantasy 15 the season pass
appeared in the North American and
Japanese PlayStation stores this week it
doesn't reveal how much the DLCs cost
individually but the past is included in
the digital premium edition of Final
Fantasy 15 which is available for
pre-order for 85 bucks the season pass
includes six different DLCs which are
listed as booster pack episode gladiolus
a holiday park episode ignis episode
prompt oh and expansion pack okay so not
the most descriptive but it does look
like a few of those are story episodes
based around three of the game's main
characters earlier this week we got a
new Pokemon Sun and Moon trailer which
revealed new versions of existing
Pokemon Sun and Moon will feature a Lola
forms named after the game's new region
which provide a new look and type for
existing Pokemon perhaps the most
dramatic of these is executors new form
which is sort of like a super tall
sentient disturbing palm tree it also
becomes a grass Dragon type instead of a
grass psychic-type the trailer also
shows off new Pokemon like the floating
Rock miniel the very odd-looking
gumshoes and the adorable grass-type
romantis Pokemon Sun and Moon is to out
under the bay team for duty black ops 3
final DLC is set to resolve a massive
zombies cliffhanger from 2008 try out
senior executive producer Jason blundell
said the fourth and final DLC pack which
will launch later this year provides the
latest installment in the zombies
storyline that originated in 2008
Oh duty world at war he explains at the
cliffhanger which depicts Samantha in a
house with Edward being pulled down to
the basement by Max after an alarm goes
off we'll all be explained in the
upcoming DLC he said I believe that the
ending of dlc for will spark a motion in
the players which is my gold niantic has
made quite a few changes to Pokemon go
in the last update and a lot of you
aren't too happy about them this week in
niantic defended themselves for removing
the 3-step tracking feature which really
wasn't working at all niantic said the
tracking feature was removed in order to
improve the underlying design they also
restricted access to the Pokemon go API
which effectively shut down the third
party cocoa vision appt niantic
explained we have limited access by
third-party services which were
interfering with our ability to maintain
quality of service for our users and to
bring Pokemon go to users around the
world the creator of Boko vision has
since written a disappointed open letter
to niantic saying the tour was only
created to bridge the gap left by the
game while the dev sort of this [ __ ] out
finally you only have to wait a few more
days for no man's sky but you'll
probably be happy to hear that hello
games are already working on a big
update game director Sean Murray took to
Twitter to say 5am at hello gains
wrapping up a month of working on our
first update lots of new features
balancing and content mari didn't
specify when this update would arrive
but given its almost done it could be
something we can expect on release day
only this week a guy by the name of
Damian bought a leaked copy of the game
for an insane amount of money posted
gameplay clips online and purported to
have finished it in 30 hours ears then
stopped because he thought creator Sean
Murray was a cool dude and he didn't
want to be the person that ruined it for
everybody no man skies drought on august
nine for ps4 and pc this week on site we
talked about what makes abs do so great
wrap up our thoughts on suicide squad
and explore the biggest changes
civilization 6 makes to the franchise
let me know we thought of our stories
this week have an awesome weekend and I
will see you again on Monday
you